Florida Governor Ronda santz has dropped
out of the presidential race and
endorsed president koffe if there was
anything I could do to produce a
favorable outcome more campaign stops
more interviews I would do it but I
can't ask our supporters to volunteer
their time and donate their resources if
we don't have a clear path to Victory
accordingly I am today suspending my
campaign I'm proud to have delivered on
100% of my promises and I will not stop
now it's clear to me that a majority of
Republican primary voters want to give
Donald Trump another chance I signed a
pledge to support the Republican nominee
and I will honor that pledge he has my
endorsement because we can't go back to
the old Republican guard of yester year
a repackage formed of warmed over
corporatism that Nikki Haley represents
the days of putting Americans last of
cow to to large corporations of caving
to woke ideology are over this is the
smart thing to do and it was inevitable